ADAM YALA: OK, great.
Well, thank you for
the great setup.
So for this section, I'm gonna
talk about some of our work
in interpreting
mammograms for cancer.
Specifically it's going to
go into cancer detection
and triage mammograms.
Next, we'll talk about
our technical approach
in breast cancer risk.
And then finally close up in
the many, many different ways
to mess up and the way
things can go wrong,
and how does it [INAUDIBLE]
clinical implementation.
So let's kind of
look more closely
at the numbers of the actual
breast cancer screening
workflow.
So as Connie already said,
you might see something
like 1,000 patients.
All them take mammograms.
Of that 1,000, on
average maybe 100
they called back for
additional imaging.
Of that 100, something
like 20 will get biopsied.
And you end up with maybe
five or six diagnoses
of breast cancer.
So one very clear thing
you see about problems
when you look at this
funnel is that way
over 99% of people that you see
in a given day are cancer-free.
So your actual
incidence is very low.
And so there's kind of a natural
question that can come up.
What can you do in
terms of modeling
if you have an even OK
cancer detection model
to raise the incidence
of this population
but automatically reading
a portion of the population
is healthy.
Does everybody just
follow that broad idea?
OK.
That's enough head nods.
So the broad idea
here is you're going
to train the cancer detection
model to try to find cancer
as well as we can.
Given that, we're
going to try to say,
what's a threshold on
a development set such
that we can kind of
say below the threshold
no one has cancer.
And if we use that
at test times,
simulating clinical
implementation, what would that
look like?
And can we actually do better
by doing this kind of process?
And the kind of broad plan of
how I'm gonna talk about this--
I'm gonna do this for
the next product as well.
Of course, we're going
to talk about the kind
of dataset collection and
how we think about, like,
you know, what is good data
and how do we think about that.
Next, the actual methodology and
go into the general challenges
when you're modeling mammograms
for any computer mission tasks,
specifically in cancer,
and also, obviously, risk.
And lastly, how we thought
about the analysis and some kind
of objectives there.
So to kind of dive into it, we
took consecutive mammograms.
I'll get back into this later.
This is actually
quite important.
We took consecutive
mammograms from 2009 to 2016.
This started off with
about 280,000 cancers.
And once we kind of filtered--
so at least one year follow up,
we ended up with
this final setting
where we had 220,000
mammograms for training
and about 26,000 for
development and testing.
And the way we had it,
it all comes to say,
is this a positive
mammogram or not?
We didn't look at
what cancers were
caught by the radiologists.
We'd say, you know, what
was cancer that was found
in any means within a year?
And where we looked to was
through the radiology, EHR,
and the Partners-- kind
of five hospital registry.
And there we were
trying to save cancer--
if anyway we can tell
a cancer occurred,
let's mart it as such regardless
of what others caught on MRI
or some kind of later stage.
And so the thing we're
trying to do here
is just mimic the
real world of what
are we trying to catch cancer.
And finally, important
details we always
split by patient so that
your results aren't just
memorizing this specific
patient didn't have cancer.
And so we have some overlap
that's some bad bias to have.
OK.
That's pretty simple.
Now let's go into the modeling.
There's going to kind
of follow two chunks.
One chunk is going to be on
the kind of general challenges,
and it's kind of shared between
the variety of projects.
And next is going to be kind
of more specific analysis
for this project.
So kind of a general
question you might be asking,
I have some image.
I have some outcome.
Obviously, this is just
image classification.
How is it different
from ImageNet?
Well, it's quite similar.
Most lessons are shared.
But there are some
key differences.
So I gave you two examples.
One of them is a
scene in my kitchen.
Can anyone tell me
what the object is?
This is not a particularly
hard question.
AUDIENCE: [Intermingled
voices] Dog.
Bear.
ADAM YALA: Right.
AUDIENCE: Dog.
ADAM YALA: It is almost
all of those things.
So that is my dog, the best dog.
OK.
So can anyone tell
me, now that you've
had some training with Connie,
if this mammogram indicates
cancer?
Well, it does.
And this is unfair for
a couple of reasons.
Let's go into, like,
why this is hard.
It's unfair in part because
you don't have the training.
But it's actually a much
harder signal to learn.
So first let's kind
of delve into it.
In this kind of task,
the image is really huge.
So you have something like a
3,200 by 2,600 pixel image.
This is a single
view of a breast.
And in that, the actual
cancer they're looking for
might be 50 by 50 pixels.
So intuitively your signal to
noise ratio is very different.
Whereas an image that--
my dog is like the entire image.
She's huge in real
life and in that photo.
And the image itself
is much smaller.
So not only do you have
much smaller images,
but you're kind of, like, the
relative size of the object
in there is much larger.
To kind of further
compound the difficulty,
the pattern you're looking
for inside the mammogram
is really context-dependent.
So if you saw that pattern
somewhere else in the breast,
it doesn't indicate
the same thing.
And so you really
care about where
in this kind of global
context this comes out.
And if you kind of
take the mammogram
at different times with
different compressions,
you would have this kind
of non-rigid morphing
of the image that's much
more difficult to model.
Whereas that's a more or
less context-independent dog.
You see that kind of
frame kind of anywhere,
you know it's a dog.
And so it's a much
easier thing to learn
in a traditional
computer vision setting.
And so the core challenge
here is that both the image
is too big and too small.
So if you're looking at just
the number of cancers we have,
the cancer might be less
than 1% of the mammogram
and about 0.7% of your
images have cancers,
even in this data set,
which is from 2000 to 2016
MGH, a massive imaging center,
in total across all of that,
you will still have
less than 2,000 cancers.
And this is super tiny
compared to regular object
classification data sets.
And this is looking at
over a million images
if you look at all the
four views of the exams.
And at the same time,
it's also too big.
So even if I downsample
these images,
I can only really fit three
of them for a single GPU.
And so this kind of limits the
batch size I can work with.
And whereas the
kind of comparable,
if I took just the
regular image net size,
I could fit batches of
128, easily happy days
and do all this
parallelization stuff,
and it's just much
easier to play with.
And finally, the actual data
set itself is quite large.
And so you have to do some--
there's nuisances to deal
with in terms of, like, just
setting up your server
infrastructure to handle
these massive data sets, also
be able to train efficiently.
So you know, the
core challenge here
across all of
these kind of tasks
is, how do we make this
model actually learn?
The core problem is that
our signal to noise ratio
is quite low.
So training ends up
being quite unstable.
And there's a kind of a
couple of simple levers
you can play with.
The first lever is often
deep learning initialization.
Next, we're gonna talk about
kind of the optimization
or architecture choice
and how this compares
to what people often
do in the community,
including in a recent
paper from yesterday.
And then finally, we're gonna
talk about something more
explicit for the triage idea and
how we actually use this model
once it's trained.
OK.
So before I go into how
we made these choices,
I'm just going to say what
we chose to give you context
before I dive in.
So we followed some
image initialization.
We use a relatively large
batch size-ish of 24.
And the way we do that
is by taking 4 GPUs
and just stepping
a couple of times
before doing an optimizer step.
So when you do a
couple rounds of back
prop first to accumulate
those gradients
before doing optimization.
And you sample balanced
batches of training time.
And for backbone architecture
we use ResNet-18.
It's just kind of,
like, fairly standard.
OK.
But as I said before, one
of the first key decisions
is how do you think about
your initialization?
So this is a figure of
ImageNet initialization
versus random initialization.
It's not any
particular experiment.
I've done this across
many, many times.
It's always like this.
Where if you use
image initialization,
your loss drops
immediately, both in
train loss and development
loss when you actually
learn something.
Whereas when you do
random initialization,
you kind of don't
learn anything.
And your loss kind of
bounds around the top
for a very long time before
it finds some region where
it quickly starts learning.
And then it will plateau
again for a long time
before quickly start learning.
And to kind of
give some context,
to give about 50 epochs takes
on the order of, like, 15,
16 hours.
And so to wait long
enough to even see
if random initialization
could perform as well
is beyond my level of patience.
It just takes too long, and
I have other experiments
to be running.
So this is more of an
empirical observation
that the image initialization
learns immediately.
And there's some kind of
questions of why is this?
Our theoretical understanding
of this is not that strong.
We have some intuitions of
why this might be happening.
We don't think it's anything
about this particular filter
of this dog is really
great for breast cancer.
That's quite implausible.
But if you look it into a lot
of the earlier research in terms
of the right kind of random
initialization for things
like revenue networks,
a lot of focus
was on does the
activation pattern not
blow up as you go
further down the line.
One of the benefits of starting
with the pre-trained network
is that a lot of
those kind of dynamics
are already figured out
for a specific task.
And so shifting from
that to other tasks
has seemed to be not
that challenging.
Another possible
area of explanation
is actually in a
BatchNorm statistics.
So if you remember, we can
only fit three images per GPU.
And the way the BatchNorm
initialization is implemented
across every deep learning
library that I know of,
it computes
independently per GPU
to minimize the kind of
inter-GPU communication.
And so it's also less able to
kind of guess from scratch.
But if you're starting with
the BatchNorm statistics
to ImageNet and just
slowly shifting it over,
it might also result in
some stability benefits.
But in general, or
like, a true deeper
theoretical understanding, but
as I said, it still eludes us.
And it isn't something I can
give too much conclusions
about, unfortunately.
OK.
So that's initialization.
And if you don't get this
right, kind of nothing
works for a very long time.
So if you're gonna start
a project in this space,
try this.
Next, another important
decision that if you don't do,
it kind of breaks, is your
optimization/architecture
choice.
So as I said before, kind of
a core problem in stability
here is this idea that our
just signal to noise ratio
is really low.
And so a very common
approach throughout a lot
of the prior work
and things I actually
have tried myself before
is to say, OK, let's
just break down this problem.
We can train at a
patch level first.
We're going to take just
subsets of a mammogram
in this little
bonding box, have it
annotated for radiology
findings like benign masses
or calcification and
things of that sort.
We're going to
pre-train on that task
to have this kind of
pixel level prediction.
And then once we're
done with that,
we're going to fine tune
that initialized model
across the entire image.
So you kind of have this
two-stage training procedure.
And actually, another paper
that came out just yesterday
does the exact same approach
with some slightly different
details.
But one of the things
we wanted to investigate
is if you just-- oh, And
the base architecture
that's always used
for this, there
is quite a few valid
options of things
that just get
reasonable performance
and ImageNet, things like
VGG, Wide ResNets and ResNets.
In my experience, they all
performed fairly similarly.
So it's kind of a
speed/benefit trade-off.
And there's an advantage to
using fully convolutional
architectures because if you
have fully connected layers
that are assumed
specific dimensionality,
you can convert them to
convolutional layers.
They're just more
convenient to start
with a full convolutional
architecture.
There's going to be
resolution invariant.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: In the last
slide when you do patches--
ADAM YALA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: How do you
label every single patch?
Are they just labeled
with a global label?
Or do you have to
actually look and catch,
and figure out what's happened?
ADAM YALA: So
normally what you do
is you have positive
patches labeled.
And then you randomly
sample other patches.
So from your annotation--
so, for example, a lot people
do this on public data sets like
the Florida DSM dataset that
has some entries,
of like, here are
benign masses, benign calcs,
malignant calcs, et cetera.
What people do then is
take those annotations.
They will randomly
select other patches
and say, if it's not
there, it's negative.
And I'm going to
call it healthy.
And then they'll
say if this bonding
box overlaps with patch
by some marginal call,
it's the same label.
So do this heuristically.
And other data sets that are
proprietary also kind of play
with a similar trick.
In general, they don't actually
label every single pixel
accordingly.
But there's relatively
minor differences
in how people do this.
But the results are fairly
similar, regardless.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: When you go from the
patch level to the full image,
if I understand correctly,
the architecture hasn't quite
changed because it's just
convolution is over a larger--
ADAM YALA: Exactly.
So the end thing right before we
do the prediction is normally--
ResNet, for example, does
a global average pool.
Channel lies across
the entire feature map.
And so they just--
for the patch level they take
in an image that's 250 by 250,
do the global average
pool across that
to make the prediction.
And when they just go up to
the full resolution image,
now you're taking a global
average pool over a 3,000
by 2,000.
AUDIENCE: And presumably there
might be some scaling issue
that you might need to adjust.
Do you do any of that?
Or are you just--
ADAM YALA: So you feed it
in at the full resolution
the entire time.
So you just-- do
you see what I mean?
So you're taking a crop.
So the resolution
isn't changing.
So the same filter map should
be able to kind of scale
accordingly.
But if you do things
like average pooling,
then you're kind of--
any one thing that has
a very high activation
will get averaged down lower.
And so, for example,
in our work,
we use max pooling to
kind of get around that.
Any other questions?
But if this looks
complicated, have
no worries because we actually
think it's totally unnecessary.
And this is the next slide.
So good for you.
So as I said before,
this kind of,
what are the problems
that signal to noise?
So one obvious thing to kind
of think about is, like, OK.
Maybe doing SGD with
a batch size of three
when the lesion is less than
1% of the image is a bad idea.
If I just take less
noisy gradients
by increasing my batch size,
which means use more GPUs,
take more steps before
doing the weight update,
we actually find that the
need to do this actually
goes away completely.
So these are experiments I did
in the publicly available data
set a while back while we
were figuring this out.
If you take this kind of
[INAUDIBLE] architecture
and fine tune with a batch
size of 2, 4, 10, 16,
and compare that to just
a one-stage training where
you just do the
[INAUDIBLE] beginning
and initialized in ImageNet
and as you use different batch
sizes, you quickly
start to close the gap
on the development AUC.
And so for all the
experiments that we do broadly
we find that we actually get
reasonably stable training
by just using a batch
size of 20 and above.
And this kind of comes down to
if you use a batch size of one,
it's just particularly unstable.
In other details that we always
sample the balanced batches.
Cause otherwise you'd
be sampling like,
20 batches before you see
a single positive sample.
You just don't learn anything.
Cool.
So that is like,
if you do that, you
don't do anything complicated.
You don't do any fancy cropping
or anything of that sort,
or like, dealing with
like VGG annotations.
We found that the actual using
VGG annotation for this task
is not actually helpful.
OK.
No questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So with
the larger batch
sizing you don't use
the magnified patches?
ADAM YALA: We don't.
We just take the whole
image from beginning.
Pretend you-- like,
can you just see
the annotation as
whole image, cancer
with less than within a year.
It's a much simpler setup.
AUDIENCE: I don't get.
That's the same thing
I thought you said you
couldn't do for memory reasons.
ADAM YALA: Oh.
So you just-- instead of--
so normally when you do,
you're going to
train the network,
the most common approach is
you do back prop and then step.
Cause you do back
prop several times,
you're accumulating the
gradients, at least in PyTorch.
And then you can
do step afterwards.
So instead of doing the
whole batch at one time,
you just do it serially.
So there you're just
trading time for space.
The minimum, though, is you have
to fit at least a single image
per GPU.
And in our case
we can fit three.
But to make this actually scale,
we use four GPUs at a time.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How much is
the trade-off with time?
ADAM YALA: So if I'm gonna
take one batch size any bigger,
I would only do it in
increments of let's say
12, because that's how much I
can fit within my set of GPUs
at the same time.
But to control the
size of the experiment
you want to have the kind of the
same number of gradient updates
per experiment.
So if I want to use
a batch size of 48,
so all my experiments, instead
of taking about half a day,
it takes about a day.
And so there's kind of,
like, this natural trade-off
as you go along.
So one of the things I
mentioned at the very end
is we're considering
some adversarial approach
for something.
And one of the annoying
things about that
is that if I have five
discriminator steps, oh my god.
My my experiment-- I'll take
three days per experiment.
And [INAUDIBLE]
update of someone
that's trying to
design a better model
becomes really slow
when the experiments
start taking this long.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So you said
the annotations did not
help with the training.
Is that because
the actual cancer
itself is not really different
from the dense tissue,
and the location of
that matters, and not
the actual granularity of the--
what is the reason?
ADAM YALA: So in general
when something doesn't help,
there's always kind of like
a possibility of two things.
One thing is that the whole
image signal kind of subsumes
that smaller scale signal.
Or there is a
better way to do it
I haven't found that would help.
And then this thing looks
to us all very hard.
As of now, so the
task we're [INAUDIBLE]
on is whole image
classification.
And so on that
task it's possible
that the kind of
surrounding context--
so when you do a patch
with an annotation,
you kind of lose the
context which it appears in.
So it's possible that just by
looking at the whole context
every time, it's as good--
you don't get any benefit from
kind of the zooming boxes.
However, we're not evaluating
on kind of an object detection
type of evaluation metric.
If you say how well we
are catching the box.
And if we were, we'd probably
have much better luck
with using the VGG annotation.
Because you might
be able to tell
some of those
discriminations by like,
this looks like a breast
that's likely to develop cancer
at all.
And the ability of
the model to do that
is part of why we
can do risk modeling.
Which is going to be the kind
of the last bit of the talk.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So do you do
the object detection
after you identify whether
there's cancer or not?
ADAM YALA: So as of now we don't
do object detection in part
because we're framing
the problem as triage.
So there is quite a
few tool kits out there
to draw more boxes
on the mammogram.
But the insight
is that if there's
1,000 things to look at,
looking at 2,000 things
you drew more boxes per image.
And it isn't
necessarily the problem
we're trying to look at.
There's quite a bit
of effort there.
And it's something we might
look into later in the future.
But it's not the
focus of this work.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So Connie was saying
that the same pattern appearing
in different parts of the breast
can mean different things.
But when you're looking at
the entire image as once,
I would worry
intuitively about whether
the convolutional
architecture is
going to be able to pick
that up or whether--
because you were looking
for a very small cancer
on a very large image.
And then you were looking
for the significance
of that very small cancer in
different parts of the image
or in different
contexts of the image.
And I'm just--
I mean, it's a pleasant
surprise that this works.
ADAM YALA: So there is kind
of like two pieces that
can help explain that.
So the first is that
if you look at, like,
the receptive fields of any
given last receptive map
at the very end of the
network, each of those
summarizes through
these convolutions
a fairly sizable
part of the image.
And so you are kind of, like,
each pixel at the very end
ends up being like something
like a 50 by 50 image.
That's by five total dimensions.
And so each part does summarize
this local context decently
well.
And when you do maximum
at the very end,
and you get some not perfect
but OK global summary, what
is the context of this image?
So something like, let's say,
some of the lower dimensions
can summarize, like, is
this a dense breast or kind
of some of the other
pattern information
that might tell you what
kind of breast this is.
Whereas any one of
them can tell you
this looks like a cancer
given its local context.
So do you have some
level summarization,
both because of the
channel-wise maxim of the end,
and because each point through
the many, many convolutions
of different strides gives you
some of that summary effect.
OK, great.
I'm going to jump forward.
So we've talked about
how to make this learn.
It's actually not
that tricky if we just
do it carefully and tune.
Now I'll talk about how to use
this model to actually deliver
on this triage idea.
So some of my choices again,
ImageNet initialization
is going to make your
life a happier time.
Use bigger batch sizes.
And architecture
choice doesn't really
matter if it's convolutional.
And the overall setup that
we do through this work
and across many
other projects we're
training independently
per image.
Now this is a harder task
because you don't actually
have the--
you're not taking any
of the other view,
you're not taking
prior mammograms.
But this is for kind of more
harder reasons than that.
We're going to get the
prediction for the whole exam
by taking the maximum
across the different images.
So if I say this breast has
cancer, the exam has cancer.
So you should get it checked up.
And at each
development epoch we're
going to evaluate the
ability of the model
to do triage task, which
I'll step into in a second.
And we're going to
kind of take the best
model that can do triage.
So you're always kind of
like, your true end metric
is what you're measuring
during training.
And you're going to
do model selection
and kind of hyper
patching based on that.
And the way we're going
to do triage and our goal
here is to mark as
many people as healthy
without missing a single
cancer that we always
would have caught.
So intuitively kind of
by taking all the cancers
that the radiologist
would have caught, what's
the probability of cancer
across these images,
and just take the minimum
of those and call that
the threshold.
That's exactly what we do.
And another detail
that's quite relevant
often is if you want
these models to output
a reasonable
probability like this
is the probability of cancer,
and you train on a 50/50 sample
the batches, by default
your model thinks
that the average
incidence is 50%.
So it's crazy
confidence all the time.
So to calibrate that one
really simple trick is you do
something called Platt's Method
where you basically just fit
like a two-parameter sigmoid
or just scale and a shift
to just--
on the development sets
to make it actually
fit the distribution.
That way the average
probability you would expect
to actually fit the incidence.
And you don't get this kind
of like crazy off-kilter
probabilities.
OK.
So analysis.
The objectives of what
we would try to do here
is kind of similar
across all the projects.
One, does this thing work?
Two, does this thing work
across all the people
it's supposed to work for?
So we did a subgroup analysis.
First we looked at
the AUC in this model.
So the ability to
discriminate cancer is not.
We did it across races.
We have across MGH, age
groups, and density categories.
And finally, how
does this relate
to radiologist's assessments?
And if we actually
use this at test time
on the test set, what
would have happened?
Kind of a simulation before a
full clinical implementation.
So overall AUC here was 82 with
some confident from 80 to 85.
And we did our analysis by age.
We found that the performance
was pretty similar
across every age group.
What's not shown here is
the confidence intervals.
So for example-- but the
kind of key core takeaway
here is that there
was no noticeable gap
in terms of by age group.
We repeated this
analysis by race,
and we saw the same trend again.
The performance kind of
ranged generally around 82.
And in places where
the gap was bigger,
the just confidence interval
was bigger accordingly due
to smaller sample sizes,
cause MGH is 80% white.
We saw the exact same
trend by density.
The outlier here is
very dense breasts.
But there's only like
100 of those on test set.
So this confidence actually
goes from like, 60 to 90.
So as far as we know for
the other three categories,
it is very much tied
to confidence interval
and very similar,
once again, around 82.
OK.
So we have a decent idea
that this model seems
at least with a
publish of MGH actually
serve the relevant
populations that
exist as far as we know so far.
The next question is, how
does the model assessment
relate to the
radiologist's assessment?
So to look at that we
looked at on the test,
if you look at the
radiologist's true positives,
false positives, true
negatives, false negatives.
Where do they fall within
the model distribution
of percentile risk?
And if there is
below the threshold,
we've got to color it in
this kind of cyan color.
And if it's above
the threshold, we're
going to color it in
this purple color.
So this is kind of
triage, not triage.
The first thing to notice--
this is the true positives--
is that there is like a
pretty kind of steep drop-off.
And so there is only
one true positive
fell below the threshold in
a test set of 26,000 exams.
So none of this difference
was statistically significant.
And the vast majority of them
are kind of this top 10%.
But you kind of see, like,
there's a clear trend here
that they kind of get piled up
towards the higher percentages.
Whereas if you look at the
false positive assessments,
this trend is much weaker.
So you still see that
there is some correlation
that there's going to more false
positives the higher amounts,
but much less stark.
And this actually means
that a lot of radiologist's
false positives we actually
place below the threshold.
And so because these assessments
are completely concordant
and we're not just modeling
what the radiologist would have
said, we get an
anticipated benefit
of actually reducing the false
positives significantly because
of the weight of disagreeing.
And finally, kind of
aiding that further,
if you look at the true
negative assessments,
there is not that much
trending between where
it falls within this.
So it shows that they're kind of
picking up on different things
and they're-- where they
disagree gives them both areas
to improve and ancillary
benefits because now we can
reduce false positives.
This directly leads into
assimilating the impact.
So one of the things we
did, we just said, OK.
If people retrospective on
the test set as a simulation
before which truly plug it
in, if people didn't rebuild
the triage threshold-- so
we can't catch any more
cancer this way, but we can
reduce false positives--
what would have happened?
So at the top we have
the original performance.
So this is looking at
100% of mammograms,
sensitivity was 98.6
with specificity of 93.
And in the simulation
the sensitivity
dropped not
significantly to 90.1,
but significantly improved
to 93.7 while looking
at 81% of the mammograms.
So this is like promising
preliminary data.
But to reevaluate this and
go forward, our next step--
let's see if-- oh.
I'm going to get to
that in a second.
Our next step is we need to
do clinical implementation
to really figure out--
because there's a
core assumption here
is that people read
it the same way.
But if you have this higher
incidence, what does that mean?
Can you focus more on the
people that are more suspicious?
And is the right way to do this
just a single threshold to not
read?
Or have a double
ended with the seniors
cause they're much more
likely to have cancer.
And so there is quite a bit
of exploration here to say,
given we have these
tools that give us
some probability of
cancer, that's not perfect,
but gives us something.
How well can we do that
to improve care today?
So as a quiz, can you tell
which of these will be triaged?
So this is no cherry-picking.
I randomly picked
four mammograms
that were below and
above the threshold.
Can anyone guess which side--
left or right-- was triaged?
This is not graded,
Chris, so you know.
AUDIENCE: Raise your hand for--
ADAM YALA: Oh yeah.
Raise your hand for the left.
OK.
Raise your hand for right.
Here we go.
Well done.
OK.
And then next step,
as I said before,
is we need to kind of push to
the clinical implementation
because that's where the
rubber hits the road.
We identify is there any
biases we didn't detect?
And we need to say, can
we deliver this value?
So the next project is on
assessing breast cancer risk.
So this is the same mammogram
I showed you earlier.
It was diagnosed with
breast cancer in 2014.
It's actually my
advisor, Regina's.
And you can see that in
2013 you see it's there.
In 2012 it looks
much less prominence.
And five years ago, really
looking at breast cancer risk.
So if you can tell
from an image that
is going to be healthy
for a long time,
you're really trying
to model what's
the likelihood of
this breast developing
cancer in the future.
Now modeling breast cancer
risk, as Connie earlier said,
is not a new problem.
It's been a quite researched
one in the community.
And the more classical
approach that we're
gonna look at other
kind of global health
factors-- the person's
age, their family history,
whether or not they've
had menopause, and kind
of any other of these kind
of facts we can sort of say
are markers of
their health to try
to predict whether this person's
at risk of developing breast
cancer.
People have thought that
the image contains something
before.
The way they've
thought about this
is through this kind of
subjective breast density
marker.
And the improvements
seen across this
are kind of marginal
from 61 to 63.
And as before,
the kind of sketch
we're going to go through is
dataset collection, modeling,
and analysis.
And dataset
collection we followed
a very similar template.
We saw from
consecutive mammograms
from 2009 to 2012 we took
outcomes from the EHR,
once again, and the
Partners Registry.
We didn't do exclusions based on
race or anything of that sort,
or implants.
But we did exclude
negatives for followup.
So if someone didn't have
cancer in three years,
but disappeared
from the system, we
didn't count them
as negatives that we
have some certainty in both
the modeling and the analysis.
And as always, we split
patients into train, dev, test.
The modeling is very similar.
It's the same kind of templated
lessons as from triage,
except we experimented with a
model that's only the image.
And for the sake of analysis,
a model that's the image model
I just talked to you
before concatenated
with those traditional risk
factors at the last layer
and trained jointly.
That make sense for everyone?
So I'm going to call that
ImageOnly an Image+RF
or hybrid.
OK.
Cool?
Our kind of goals
for the analysis.
As before, we want to
see does this model
actually serve the
whole population?
Is it going to be discriminative
across race, menopause status,
the family history?
And how does it relate to kind
of classical portions of risk?
And are we actually
doing any better?
And so just diving
directly into that,
assuming there's no questions.
Good.
Just to kind of remind you,
this is the kind of the setting.
One thing I forgot to mention--
that's why I had the slide here
to remind me--
is that we excluded
cancers from the first year
from the test set.
So there is truly a negative
screening population.
That way we kind of
disentangle cancer detection
from cancer risk.
OK.
Cool.
So Tyrer-Cuzick is the kind of
prior state-of-the-art model.
It's a model based
out of the UK.
Their developer is
someone named Sir Cuzick,
who was knighted for this work.
It's very commonly used.
So that one had an AUC of 62.
Our image-only model
had an AUC about 68.
And hybrid one had an AUC of 70.
So you know, what is
this kind of AUC thing
gives you when you look
using a risk model.
What it gives you is the
ability to build better
high-risk and low-risk cohorts.
So in terms of looking
at high-risk cohorts,
our best model place about
30% of all the cancers
in the population
in the top 10%,
and 3% of all the
cancers in the bottom 10%
compared to 18 and 5 to
the prior state of the art.
And so what this
enables you to do,
if you're going to
say that this 10%
should actually
qualify for MRI, you
can start fighting this
problem of majority
of people that get
cancer don't have MRI,
and the majority of people
that get it don't need it.
It's all about, is your
risk model actually
place the right people
into the right buckets.
Now we saw that this trend of
outperforming the prior state
of the art held across races.
And one of the things that
was kind of astonishing
was that though Tyrer-Cuzick
performed on white women, which
makes sense because
it was developed only
using white women in the UK.
It was worse than
random [INAUDIBLE]
for African-American women.
And so this kind of
emphasizes the importance
of this kind of
analysis to make sure
that the kind of
data that you have
is reflective of the population
that you're trying to serve
and actually doing the
analysis accordingly.
So we saw that our model
kind of held across races
and as well across--
we see this trend
from across
pre-postmenopausal and with
and without family history.
One thing we did in terms of
a more granular comparison
of performance, if
we just look at kind
of like the risk thirds for
our model and the Tyrer-Cuzick
model, what's the
trend that you see
or the cases where kind
of like which one is right
that's kind of ambiguous.
And what I should
show in these boxes
is the cancer incidence
prevalence in the population.
So the darker the box,
the higher the incidence.
And on the right-hand
side are just
random images from cases
that fit within those boxes.
Does that make
sense for everyone?
Great.
So a clear trend that you
see is that, for example,
if TCv8 calls you a high
risk but we call it low,
that is a lower incidence
than if we called it medium
and they call it low.
So kind of like you kind of
see this straight column-wise
pattern showing that
discrimination truly does
follow the deep learning model
and not the classical approach.
And by looking at the
random images that
were selected in case
where we disagree,
it supports the notion
that it's not just
that the column is just
the most dense, crazy,
dense looking breast, that
there's something more subtle
it's picking up that's actually
indicative of breast cancer
risk.
Kind of a very
similar analysis we
looked at as if we look at just
by a traditional breast density
as labeled by the original
radiologist on the development
set or on the test
set, we end up
seeing the same trend where
if someone is non-dense
we call them high risk.
They're much higher
risk than someone
that is dense than
we call low risk.
And as before, the
kind of real next step
here to make this truly valuable
and truly useful is actually
implementing a clinically
seamless prospectively
and with more centers and
kind of more population to see
does this work and does it
deliver the kind of benefits
that we care about.
And viewing what is
the leverage of change
once you know that
someone is high risk?
Perhaps MRI, perhaps
more frequent screening.
And so this is the kind
of gap between having
a useful technology
on the paper side
to an actual useful
technology in real life.
So I am moving on schedule.
So now I'm gonna talk
about how to mess up.
And it's actually
quite interesting.
There is like, so many ways.
And I fall into them a few
times myself, and it happens.
And kind of
following the sketch,
you can mess up in
dataset collection.
That's probably the
most common by far.
You can mess up in modeling,
which I'm doing right now.
And it's very sad.
And you can mess up in analysis,
which is really preventable.
So in dataset collection,
enriched data sets
are the kind of the most common
thing you see in this space.
You find in a public
data set that's
most likely going to be like
50-50 cancer, not cancer.
And oftentimes these
datasets collect
can have some sort of
bias within the way
it was collected.
So it might be that you have
negative cases from less
centers than you
have positive cases.
Or they're collected
from different years.
And actually, this
is something we ran
into earlier in our own work.
Once upon a time,
Connie and I were
in Shanghai for the opening
of a cancer center there.
And at that time we had all the
cancers from the MGH dataset,
about 2,000.
But the mammograms were still
being collected annually
from 2012-- from 2009.
So at that time, we only had,
like, half of the negatives
by year, but all of the cancers.
And all of a sudden
I had to-- you
know, I came from the slightly
more complicated model,
as one often does.
I looked at several
images at the same time.
And my AUC went up to like, 95.
And I had all this, like,
bouncing off the wall.
And then in-- you know, I
had some suspicion of like,
wait a second.
This is too high.
This is too good.
And we completely realized
that all these numbers
were kind of a myth.
But this level of--
kind of if you do these
kind of case control things,
you can oftentimes,
unless you're
very careful about the
way it was constructed,
you could easily run
into these issues.
And your testing set won't
protect you from that.
And so having a clean
dataset that truly
follows the kind of spectrum
we expect to use it in--
i.e., a natural
distribution, collected
through routine clinical
care is important to say
will it behave as we
actually want it to be used.
In general, the only--
some of this you can think
through in first principle.
But it kind of
stresses the importance
of actually testing
this prospectively
in external validation to try to
see does this work when I take
away some of the
biases in my dataset,
and being really
careful about that.
The common approach
of just controlling
by age or by density
is not enough
when the model can catch
really fine-grained signals.
How to mess up in modeling.
So there's been adventures
in this space as well.
One of the things I've
recently discovered
is that the actual
mammography machine
device that the
machine was captured
on-- so you saw a
bunch of mammograms
probably from
different machines--
has an unexpected
impact on the model.
So the actual probability
distribution--
the distribution of cancer
probabilities by the model
is not independent
of the device.
That's something we're
going through now.
We actually ran into
this while working
on clinical implementation
is like this kind
of conditional adversarial
training set up
to try to rectify this issue.
It's important.
So this is much harder to
catch based on first principle.
But it's important to think
through as you kind of really
start demoing out
your computations.
This will kind of-- these
issues pop up easily,
and they're harder to avoid.
And lastly, and I
think probably one
that's probably
the most important
is messing up in analysis.
So it's quite common
in the previous section
in this field--
yes.
AUDIENCE: With the
adversarial up there,
just to understand what you
do, do you that discriminate
or predict the machine?
And then you train against that?
ADAM YALA: So my answer
is going to be two parts.
One, it doesn't work as
well as I want it to yet.
So really who knows?
But my best hunch
in terms of what's
been done before for other
kind of work, specifically
in radio signals, is they use
a conditional adversarial.
So you're free to discriminate
at both the label and the image
presentation.
You have to try to
predict out the device
to try to take away the
information that's not just
contained within the
label distribution.
And that's been shown to be very
helpful for people trying to do
[INAUDIBLE] detection
based off on Wi-Fi--
or not Wi-Fi-- but
like, radio waves.
And the [INAUDIBLE]
but also, it seems
to be the most common approach
I've seen in literature.
So it's something that
I'm going to try soon.
I haven't implemented it.
It was just GPU time
and kind of waiting
to queue up the experiment.
And the last part in
terms of how to mess up
is this kind of analysis.
One thing that's
common is people
assume that's it kind of
like synthetic experiments
or the same thing as
clinical implementation.
Like, people do reader
studies very often.
And it's quite common
to see that when
you do reader studies that
it doesn't actually-- like,
you might find that
computer detection does
a huge difference
in reader studies.
And it's-- Connie actual showed
it was harmful in real life.
And it's important to kind
of like, do these real world
experiments that we can
say what is happening
and just them the real
benefit that I expected.
And a hopefully less
common nowadays mistake
is that oftentimes people
exclude all inconvenient cases.
So there was a paper
yesterday that just came out
that the cancer detection used a
kind of patched-up architecture
which would read more
closely into their details,
they excluded all
women with breasts
that they considered too
small by some threshold
for like modeling convenience.
But that might
disproportionately
affect specifically Asian
women in that population.
And so they didn't do
a subgroup analysis
for all the different
races, so it's
hard to know what
is happening there.
If your population
is mostly white,
which it is at MGH, and
is at a lot of the centers
that these colleges
have developed,
are reporting the
average that you
see isn't enough to
really validate that.
And so you can have things
like Tyrer-Cuzick model
that are worse than random
and especially harmful
for African-American women.
And so guarding
against that is you
can do a lot of that
based on first principle.
But some of these things
you can only really find out
by actively monitoring to say,
is there any subpopulation
that I didn't think about a
priority that could be harmed?
And finally, so I talked
about clinical deployments.
We've actually done
this a couple times.
And I'm going to switch
over to Connie real soon.
In general, what
you want to do is
you want to make it as easy
as plausible and possible
for the in-house IT
team to use your tool.
We've gone through this with--
not like-- I don't--
depends on how you count.
It's like once for density
and then like three times
at the same time.
But I spent, like, many
hours sitting there.
And the broad way that we
set it up so far is we just
have a kind of
docker as container
to manage a web app
that holds the model.
This web app has kind of a
backup processing toolkit.
So the kind of steps that
all of our deployments
follow and I look
under unified framework
is the IT application
would get some images out
of the PAC system.
It will send it
over to application.
We're going to convert to the
PNG in the way that we expect,
because we kind of encapsulate
this functionality.
Run for the models, send it
back, and then write it back
to the EHR.
One of the things I ran into
was that they didn't actually
know how to use things like
HTTP because it's not actually
normal within their
infrastructure.
And so being cognizant that
some of these more, like,
tech standard things
like just HTTP requests
and responses and stuff is
less standard within the inside
of their infrastructure
and kind of looking up
how to actually do these
things in like C Sharp,
or whatever language
they have, has
been really what's enabled
us to end block these things
and actually plug it in.
And that is it for my part.
So I'm gonna hand
it back-- oh, yes.
AUDIENCE: So you're writing
stuff in the IT application
in C Sharp to do API requests?
ADAM YALA: So
they're writing it.
I just meet them to tell
them how to write it.
But yes.
So like, in general,
like, there's libraries.
So like, the entire
environment is in Windows.
And Windows has a
very poor support
for lots of things
you would expect
it to have a good support for.
So there was like,
if you wanted to send
HP requests for like
a multipart form
and just put the
images in that form,
apparently that has bugs in
it in like, Windows whatever
version they use today.
And so that vanilla
version didn't work.
Windows for Docker
also has bugs.
And I had to set up this kind
of locking function for them
to like, automatically table
locks inside the container.
And it just doesn't work
in Windows for Docker.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] questions
because he is short on time.
ADAM YALA: Yeah.
So we can get to
this at the end.
I want to hand off to Connie.
If you have any
questions, grab me after.